100 years since women got the vote with
a record 32% female MPs in Parliament
you would have hoped that things were
improving for women in Westminster but
when it comes to abuse is getting worst
we spoke to 30 female MPs 29 of the 30
told us they've received abusive
messages in the last year 16 more than
half said they've had death threats and
25 of them 86% said the abuse is getting
worse in the week of International
Women's Day it feels like a good time to
reflect on where we are on the journey
towards gender equality now I've been
working in Westminster for more than a
decade and I've been really shocked by
the explosion in abuse that's been
directed towards MPs and the real worry
of course is that it's going to put
women off coming to work in Parliament
at a breakfast organized by their world
a charity run by Sarah Brown guests had
their own priorities I would end all fgc
in the world and FDC is just female
genital cutting
that's the one thing I'm interested in
well I'm interested in lots of things
the mainly interested in cake but second
to cake I'm interested in making sure no
young girls at all cut in this world I'm
not sure we have achieved equality we
look at the kind of gender pay gap who
disparity I think we had made progress
and that should be recognized but I
still think we have some way to go and I
think we need to still keep the
attention I don't want any
fifteen-year-old girl watching this to
think that they should not be involved
in politics because they should be in
politics we need eight more women and
please on the Labour benches to be 50%
so make sure it's you we caught up with
Sarah Brown after the event
15 million girls another same foot in a
school why is that happening and what
impact does it have on their lives well
if you look at who's out of school
around the world and why they're out of
school it'll be poverty or conflict or
crisis that's causing that and girls are
always on the sharp end of that girls
are the chosen last to go to school the
boys often get sent to school first
where there's a choice of how many can
go to school girls are for their own
safety their families might keep them at
home and then also you've got other
risks to girls whether it's early
marriage the consequences of female
genital cutting which I know is a big
issue at the moment where they're
starting to be some progress child labor
child trafficking all of these issues
have a disproportionately large effect
on girls and can keep them away from
school but conversely when a girl gets a
chance to go to school she's improving
her chances have cut economically for
the future
she's also far less likely to marry
early she'll have greater choice over
how many children she has when she has
those children the choices that she'll
get to make in her life one thing that
you hear quite a lot of around
International Women's Day is yes things
are bad in many countries across the
world but here in the UK things are fine
aren't they we've pretty much got gender
equality and we is that an assessment
you agree with do we need International
Women's Day here in the UK I think you
need International Women's Day
everywhere in the world and that include
to the UK and I think where you've got
families that are living in extreme
poverty and facing those challenges
every day there's going to be a sharp
effect on girls for what what the impact
is for them and I think we need to pay
very close attention to that kind of
thing do you mean I think if a girl
isn't being able to afford sanitary
protection and that's keeping them out
of school I think I think affecting
girls and boys but making sure they've
had a decent meal making sure they're
learning properly so some of these
things are around girls and boys and a
common across poverty but you always
need to look at what the opportunities
are for girls who are caught on that
sharp end and to look out for them and
at the other end I think we're we're
looking at young women entering the
workplace how women connect with each
other and support each other I see huge
progress but we still do have a pay gap
and we still do have issues that we need
to address to get women right to the top
in leadership positions across all all
organisations it feels to me as if and
one of the big issues facing women in
politics in particular but also women
more generally today is what's happening
on social media and with the internet
has been a lot of focus recently on
female peas talking about some of the
abuse that they're getting and death
threats rape facts and putting panic
alarms you know in their homes is that
something that you're worried you I've
not had a lot on it but maybe my having
this interview I'll be inviting but
exactly I've I was an early adopter of
Twitter I used Twitter very extensively
during the time living in Downing Street
because it provided an opportunity for
me to have that public profile that I
thought warranted the position you need
to put some of yourself in the public
domain and share what's going on because
you're in a position that has an impact
on other people's lives but of course
the web's changed it's the 30th
anniversary of the World Wide Web this
year and I know that there'll be quite a
lot of celebrations of that during the
course of this year but there's also the
caution and the complexities and the
social consequences from it so I think
we need to take all of that seriously
and the very specific issue around the
danger to women with that I think
there's danger to men and women I have
to say but you know knowing that you
know with the death of Joe Cox I think
that heightened awareness that was a
truly truly tragic outcome to something
that we think came from having a public
profile having you know a presence kind
of a digital presence so I don't know
that we'll ever really know the reasons
but it feels like those are the serious
consequences you've also been talking
about about and trying to find a and use
the number-10 role that you had opening
the door to lots of different people in
I'm I always imagined that it must be
quite a difficult role being Prime
Minister's spouse and particularly for
someone such as yourself is a very
successful very strong independent woman
how did you find it because Gordon had
been at number 11 for such a long time
before for a decade before I was used to
a role of having a you know husband a
partner who was a political figure and
had his job and his role and for the
most part was able to lead a fairly
normal life the move to number 10 was a
bigger change than I anticipated it
would be
because you suddenly find yourself in a
spotlight and awful lot more and not
very wishing for it but I could still
carry on with a lot of things but I
think I used I hope I did I used the
opportunity of being there to engage
with the opportunity and understand the
privilege that I had which is why
bringing people through the door was so
important but also engaging in different
campaigns I took the opportunity to it
was a range of things but I led the
global maternal mortality campaign but I
also was involved in campaigns to help
bees and to go and visit I worked with a
domestic violence charity I work with
the Mackay cancer care centres I was
volunteering with a lot of different
organizations that could benefit from my
being there mmm and it feels as well is
it's not exactly a job does it have a
job description does it but at the same
time there's a very particular role that
you have to play kind of feels that you
need to be kind of comfortable not too
forceful I don't agree with that I think
it's absolutely not a job it is also not
a role there's no official type you're
not a First Lady because you're a head
of government not a head of state and
therefore it I think it is a difficult
place for a spouse to occupy and I would
defend the right of any
in that role to do as much or as little
as they like you know if you have a
young family there as I did a large part
of your time is devoted to that so there
isn't a set role or set things that you
need to do so it's there to do something
with and create that opportunity but
you're also there at the time you're
there and everything else is going on
the business of government is that
priority and then protecting your family
life is is the other priority we've then
got a man at the minute of course who is
the spouse of the Prime Minister and I
just wonder if you think any of the kind
of coverage of Philip marries been a bit
different to some of the women who've
gone before him I think there is
differences in the way we talk about
people in different roles and the kind
of gendered roles that we give people I
don't think there's much written about
mr. Mays outfits and what he wears
whereas I always felt that I was being
asked that question and maybe things can
move on from that in time I think the
purpose of International Women's Day is
exactly so we can flag up the issues
about those differences in discrepancies
and if we always fall into those very
strict gendered roles and expectations
then we really don't progress together
as humanity